تسلك العمله الايرانيه مسار الانحراريا
سبق لليرتين السوريه واللبنانيه عند
خالتها في نفقه
ورغم اقاله رئيس البنك المركزي الايراني
صالح عيادي وتعيين محمد رضا برازيل بدلا
منه لا يبدو كبح تدهور العمله الايرانيه
في متناول السلطات الايرانيه
في وقت فقد فيه التومان الايراني نحو ربع
قيمته في شهرين فقط ما جعل هذا التغيير لا
يعد حلا كافيا وفقا لخبراء اقتصاديين
صحيفه ارمان ميل الاصلاحيه الايرانيه ذكرت
انه من الخطا انتظار معجزه يقودها رئيس
البنك المركزي الجديد بالاضافه الى انه لا
جدوى من هذه التغييرات ما دامت السياسه
العامه للنظام الايراني غير قابله لتعديل
مسارها والعلاقات بين ايران ودول العالم
شبه منقطعه جراء العزله الدوليه والعقوبات
المفروضه على طهران بسبب قمعها الاحتجاجات
يضاف اليها التورط الايراني في تسليح
روسيا بالطائرات المسيره التي تستهدف
منشات المدنيه الاوكرانيه بينها البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه ما تسبب ايضا لايران
بخساره الموقف الاوروبي الوسطي وجنوحه
اكثر نحو الموقف الامريكي وبالتالي عقوبات
اوروبيه بعد الامريكيه التضخم ايضا مشكله
كبيره في ايران على ضوء الارقام القياسيه
التي يسجلها
تضخم يترافق مع انخفاض في قيمه التمان من
نحو
330,000 الى
430,000, مقابل الدولار الامريكي